This episode is brought to you by movie.
What's up guys, Michael here with a new episode of book versus film. Today,
we want to chat about one of literature and cinema's greatest heroes,
a true mensch kind of guy. You can really root for just kidding.
We're talking American psycho.
And of course the titular psycho Patrick Bateman,
both the film and novel having gendered serious controversy author, Bret Easton,
Ellis received a numerous death threats after the book's publication.
And Leonardo DiCaprio was talked out of starting in the film by feminist
activists, Gloria Steinem, and both versions are provocative, brutally violent,
and often quite funny.
I'm into, uh, uh, murders and executions. Mostly. Do you like it? Well,
it depends why. Well,
most guys I know who work in mergers and acquisitions really don't like it.
But there are also two very distinct works and their differences can affect the
way we interpret them.
What's more the differences raise some pretty cool questions.
Like is the book boring on purpose or what happens to the meaning of a scene
when you flipped a perspective? So instead of comparing business cards,
let's compare American psycho books versus film.
And obviously spoilers ahead for both.
Let's start by looking at the similarities,
both follow the same fundamental timeline,
which sees label obsessed has a for a good business card.
Yuppie Patrick Bateman,
as he goes from saying and thinking violent things to living his very best
serial killer life. He takes out his anger on unhoused people, sex workers,
and the occasional wealthy foe. In the meantime,
he has a complete meltdown and pretends to snag a reservation at Dorsia.
We're totally booked. Really? That's great. No,
I said we are totally booked two at nine. Perfect. See you then.
On top of the same basic trajectory,
many of the films best moments are cribbed directly from the novel from Bateman.
Losing is over arrivals business card to his confused homoerotic encounter to
some choice quotes about women. If they have a good point.
Personality and they're not great looking and who cares?
Just say hypothetically, okay, what if they have a good personality?
I know, I know there are no girls with good personalities.
But of course, if they were carbon copies,
this video would be over and you'd be very bored. Well,
there are plenty of things. The movie leaves out, presumably for time,
we're talking about the changes that feel most important,
which brings us to the differences.
We spent a lot of time picking apart American psycho to find these comparisons.
There is nothing we love more than a movie that requires some over analization.
It's one of the best parts about movie going. And if you feel the same,
then we think you should check out this week.
Sponsor movie movie is a curated streaming service showing exceptional films
from around the globe every day.
Movie premieres a new film from timeless classics to festival fresh gems.
There's always something new to discover.
Every movie they show is hand selected and includes an hour.
Take explaining why the film is worth your time.
They also feature director retrospectives,
the magic specials and more it's like your own personal film festival right in
your home.
Right now you can check out the exclusive streaming premiere of the celebrated.
Dromedy give me Liberty ahead at Sundance and con and the winner of the
John Cassavetes award at this year in the spirit awards,
you can check this out and also discover hundreds of other great films,
handpicked by movies, curators for free. All you have to do is send to me a
movie.com/wisecrack to get 30 days free.
That's a movie.com/wisecrack for a whole month of great cinema for free.
Now back to the show difference, number one, the violence,
most conversations about American psycho inevitably revolve around the violence.
So let's start there. Well,
both the film and the novel have plenty to offer any fan of gory horror.
There's really no comparison.
The violence in the novel is by our rough estimates,
at least 650%, more horrifying, more explicit,
more creative and more innocence destroying than the film on
screen.
Much of the violence is alluded to a woman will disappear and then reappear on
screen with a bloody nose.
Blood will splatter as a victim is impaled in the face,
but we won't actually see that port base or Patrick will lovingly finger a
lock of hair of one of his presumed victims,
like a total freak by contrast Eastern Allison's depictions of the most deranged
violence.
The worst of which is reserved for women attack you in your poor brain,
like your,
the one being hit in the head with a nail gun Bateman tortures his victims with
steak knives,
rips many eyeballs out of many sockets and cooks one of his victims into a human
sausage while sobbing and says,
I can't tell them from cooking any of this correctly
because I'm crying too hard.
And I never really cooked anything before to be clear,
he's talking about a human body. Oh,
and he also tries to mail these shriveled heart of another victim to her mom,
and also stabs a child and pushes his dying body behind a garbage can.
And that's not even the worst of it.
It's just what we think might not get as the monetized,
the comparatively toned down violence in the film seems like a reasonable
change. Film is a much more stimulating medium.
There are things we can tolerate in written form that might just be too much for
us on screen director, Mary Heron and screenwriter,
Gwen of your Turner were meticulous about it. Calibrating,
what types of violence counted as satire versus exploitation?
And what point does he a woman's body harmed on screen?
Stop making a point and start making a really gross and troubling statement.
However, there's an argument to be made though.
I'm not sure if I'm buying it that it's the book's violence that makes it so
effective as a skating commentary on 1980s, grievance,
superficial reality and rendering Bateman. So shocking.
So absurdly and deranged really violent.
The book ensures that we'll forgive him nothing.
While movie Bateman is gross and awful and very,
very disturbing his behavior doesn't even near the book standard of violence.
It's possible that the movie's relative restraint shielded the audience from
some of the books impact by concealing the worst of Bateman's violence and the
movie he's deranged. Sure.
But in the book he's positively inhuman someone we can't identify with.
And contrast movie Maven is still revered by certain corners of dude culture.
In 2005, a Bateman action figure was in high demand these days,
and I'm not making this up.
The Bateman skincare line has brought in masculine vanity to the masses and lots
of men, dream of imitating his well cloth ways.
We're not saying the books over the top violence is better,
especially if you don't want to spring for therapy.
After we're just saying that each works approach to the violence creates its own
unique meaning in the context of the narrative. Okay. Um,
enough about pan frying human flesh for one video because the violence,
isn't the only big difference.
If you've read the book you might've noticed it's well orange,
which brings us to difference. Number two,
the movie is enthralling and unlike away, Annabelle,
the book is often boring as hell on purpose.
Mary Harron's film adaptation as brisk pacing and is in academic terms,
a blast from beginning to end.
The book is something else entirely.
This 400 page screed is on Easton.
Ellis's part above all meant to be a skating take on a yuppie culture.
As a result. He wants you to hate this particular yuppie.
And as we mentioned before, in regards to human bratwurst,
he really succeeds by making Bateman not only 100% psychopath,
but also 100% boring as hell. The film might share some of the novels,
banal and comedic conversations about material wealth, but in the book,
Bateman becomes even more hateable with recurring passages,
documenting his superficial obsessions that are so boring as to be utterly
intolerable. Here, he is describing a Christmas party buffet.
A long folding table has been covered with a red tablecloth and is jammed with
pans and plates and bowls of roasted hazelnuts and lobster and oyster
bisques and celery root soup with apples and balloon caviar on toast points
and creamed onions and roast goosed with Chestnut stuffing.
Don't worry. There's more.
And caviar and puff pastry and vegetable tarts with tapenade roast,
duck and roast rack of veal.
And the vegetables straight on all of our salad and scallops and bruschetta with
marscapone and like triples.
There's still more,
but you get the picture and yell at us in the comments all you want,
but we know that you know,
that you were at least a little bored during that four page dissertation on
Whitney Houston being inside Patrick Bateman's head is a lot of things,
but it's at most points aggressively and decidedly.
Un-fun his obsession with the finer things in life is spiraled into something
completely deranged.
Sometimes that means diagramming every single designer behind every single piece
of clothing on every single person in this fancy,
new Southern California restaurant,
until you wish he would gouge your eyeballs out.
Sometimes that means reciting every single appliance or decoration in his sad,
expensive minimalist apartment.
And that always means describing every piece of fancy food on the table,
including the side dish condiments and some very Merry eighties or Bay flavors
and the film.
We get a fair amount of voiceover offering some insight into the complete and
utter banality of being Patrick Bateman.
After I removed the ice pack,
I use a deep pore cleanser lotion in the shower.
I use a water activated gel cleanser,
then a honey almond, Bonnie scrum.
In both versions,
his inner monologue spotlights the compulsive nature of someone who's unable to
experience life beyond luxury, commodities, sex, and violence, but in the book,
there's no escaping that inner monologue more than anything.
This speaks to the relative freedom that fiction writers are given in comparison
to screenwriters and filmmakers Easton Ellis can rant for seven and a half pages
about QB Lewis and the news,
but that's got to be condensed to a one and a half minutes still long feeling
monologue.
As he prepares to acts his business rival film structure is for the most part,
much more rigid.
You've basically got to hit a compelling mid point by the end of the first hour.
It's almost impossible to have it more than 400 pages into two hours.
And it makes sense that the redundancies like the counting 15 references to
Donald Trump would be the first to go.
Instead of seemingly dozens of conversations about stuff like how to wear a vest
beneath the suit. We get an errant line.
Now, John, you've got to wear clothes and proportions.
Instead of a good Jillian scenes fighting over reservations.
We get a quick conversation. As a result, movie,
Bateman is more tolerable and much more entertaining in contrast being inside
Bateman's head for 400 pages reveals the absolute banality of yuppy
existence in all its Armani drenched glory. However, Patrick Bateman,
isn't the only character in this sort of tale. What about the women?
Let's break it down. Difference. Number three, the female perspective.
It doesn't take a lot of reflection to realize that Patrick's malevolent has a
favorite target women, but through small changes in perspective,
the film was able to do things. The book, otherwise can't Easton Ellis,
his novel is situated so deeply in the crevices of Patrick Bateman's disturbing
brain that there's no escaping his perspective. And when it comes to women,
let's just say that perspective is less than flattering.
The nicest thing he'll call a he's about to murder is a hard body,
which hopefully we don't have to explain to you is absolutely dehumanizing.
Whether he's feeding his fiance,
a urinal cake disguised as a good diamond chocolate or swearing at his ex,
as he maces her in the eyes while nailing her fingers to a piece of wood,
he displays nothing but to stain and scorn from 99.9% of women with
perhaps the exception of the secretary, Jean what's more,
the book's depiction of the women is overwhelmingly a mirror image of the men,
narcissistic, petty, and Craven, and their obsession with the material world.
However, while male superficial reality is the name of Bateman's game.
Hearing it from women really grinds his goat like Evelyn obsessing over her
Waldorf salad. They have the best Waldorf salad in town at the rainbow room.
Did you like mine? Did you like my Waldorf salad, honey,
these depictions necessarily make it harder to connect with the women.
Bateman wounds emotionally and physically his wrote dehumanizing descriptions of
either sexy or torturing women start to blur together.
In contrast to the film,
both written and directed by women treats the female characters different in
part, because we're somewhat free from the prison of Bateman's perspective. Now,
if you really pay attention,
you'll find that not a single male character says anything that isn't remarkably
petty, superficial, or narcissistic. They prattle on about sex, food,
and clothes to such access as the scene, completely devoid of personality.
In contrast the women in the film though,
displaying varying levels of superficial reality,
generally possess some emotional depth outside the prism of Bateman's narration.
This allows us to genuinely feel for them.
There's Evelyn watching her relationship fall apart in slow motion.
Patrick, we should do it.
Do get married, have a wedding. No, I can't take the tunnel for it.
And wondering out loud by Bateman's and capable of feeling.
No I'm in, I'm in touch with humanity.
The book, this exchange is annoying for Bateman who tells us to me,
she looks like a big black ant,
a big black ant and an original Christian LaCroix eating a urinal
cake. And I almost start laughing.
But in the film we genuinely feel for American icon Reese Witherspoon.
And of course there's Jean who adores Bateman with a startling innocence in both
iterations while all of these basic narratives exist in the novel.
They're so filtered through.
Bateman's that we simply can't feel for the women the way we do in the film.
But the character who is most interesting to us is Christie right before her
first threesome with Bateman,
she exchanges a look with the other sex worker that demonstrates their mutual
scorn for him. While that look is described in the novel, it's again,
filtered through Patrick's view.
He doesn't actually pick up on the extent to which these ladies hate him.
The second time Kristy goes back to his apartment, accepting his generous check.
Presumably out of desperation, the book describes her as cautious,
scared and impassive. However, in the film,
her solid performance and deadly glare are uncomfortable to watch here.
We see what she likely felt in the book. I hatred for Bateman,
that he was too self-centered to even notice, but it's one onscreen.
Christy is murdered.
That things get really tragic and cinematically interesting.
And then novel she's brutally tortured in ways so shocking that we will
unfortunately remember them on our deathbeds in the film.
Things happen very differently. Now at an earlier moment,
we see Patrick doing sit-ups while lodging, Texas chainsaw massacre,
which is for sure, totally normal and chill thing to do,
but it's also a slight reference to what Christie's death will look like in the
book. Christy is tied up in gag while Patrick kills the other member of their
threesomes and the film she realizes he's attacking the other woman promptly
leaps up and tries to get the hell out.
What follows her running from Bateman and his chainsaw is shot quite similarly
to this moment in that iconic horror film,
where the protagonist runs for her life.
Also trying to escape a madman with a chainsaw.
So for a brief moment in the film,
we are completely immersed in Christie's Headspace.
We can completely empathize with it and we desperately want to see her escape
perhaps more so than any character in the film.
Christie is a real person who sees Bateman for what he really is humanizing
Bateman's victim. This way is a powerful statement on Heron's part.
And it's a larger reason that many consider this film to be subversively
feminist, despite popular backlash,
Heron forces us to acknowledge Christie's humanity to tragic effect. Of course,
that is if you believe that Patrick Bateman serial killing really happened,
which brings us to difference. Number four reality.
One of the lingering questions about American psycho is whether or not this
whole killing spree happened in real life for took place in Bateman's rapidly,
disintegrating psyche,
obviously both the film and novel share the clue that Paul Allen is apparently
alive and well.
This clue is a little more suspect in the novel because everyone is constantly
confusing. Male identities,
which happens just a few salient times in the film in both versions though, it,
at least it feels possible that the lawyer merely had dinner with someone who
looks like Paul Allen also volts share a creepy moment.
When Patrick goes to cleanup Allen's apartment and meets an intimidating real
estate agent who tells Patrick to go away and don't make any travel plays in the
film.
This is as close as we get to a clue that somebody knows what he's been up to
compounded with the chilling suspicion that this real estate agent covered up
his murders to more easily sell the apartment. However,
there's one scene in the book that is far more revealing in it.
Bateman's cab driver recognizes him and calls him out as the madman who killed a
fellow cabby named salty.
He also reports that Bateman's face is on a wanted poster downtown,
this literal confrontation,
no one time somebody looks him in the eye and accuses him of being a murderer is
powerful in the novel. Bateman says, I feel naked.
Suddenly tiny. My mouth tastes metallic then gets worse.
Literally Bateman is cut down to size when faced with accusations about his
behavior,
the cabbie then holds up a gun and Rob's Bateman of his precious Rolex.
And Wayfair's informing him that there is no monetary reward being offered for
turning him in. It's interesting. This scene is again,
scathing commentary.
The cabbie's moral indignation is overridden by his desire for expensive
material goods. He could try to turn Bateman in,
but there's no financial incentive to do that.
So he doesn't bother pretty dark, but more importantly,
this scene does a lot of work to suggest that Bateman's killings are real and
that he could face consequences for his actions.
The movie doesn't have this scene, and that really matters. In fact,
it contributes to the reasonable belief among some fans that the killings are
actually all in Patrick's head. Eastern.
Alice has said that he's not sure himself.
However Heron has said Patrick was definitely a serial killer though.
Some of the movies more outrageous events were intended to be ambiguous that
said Heron has commented that her biggest regret was people keep coming out of
the film, thinking that it's all a dream.
And I never intended that the cabbie stealing a Rolex scene in the book makes
Bateman's murderous, inclinations, less ambiguous, and pretty much assures us.
At least the Patrick's murder spree has some basis in reality.
And speaking of Rolex's, that brings us to difference number five,
the Rolex in the novel Bateman makes more than two dozen references to his
beloved Rollings. However,
apparently Rolex wasn't so cool with being the favorite watch of cinema's most
hideous serial killer, and wouldn't sign off on any references. As a result,
the movie doesn't contain a single utterance of that most sacred word Rolex
rather when one woman reaches for Patrick's hand, he merely says, touch the,
watch this though.
It seems incidental is actually super important because nah,
just kidding.
It's just a fun piece of trivia with absolutely no bearing on the plot.
So Sue us. But what do you guys think?
Do these differences change their respective meanings of the film in the book,
which is better? Or is that a dumb question? Because each is unique.
Tell us your thoughts in the comments is always huge.
Thanks to our patrons for all your support lovingly swipe that subscribe button
like you're Patrick Bateman,
applying an anti-aging Ibom and be sure to ring that bell as always.
Thanks for watching later.
[Inaudible].